ja das was viele befürchtet hatten ist
jetzt eingetreten die
weltgesundheitsorganisation hat die
korona epidemie jetzt als pandemie
eingeordnet da sie nahezu in jedem land
ausgebrochen ist
auf der welt mit mehr oder weniger
fallzahlen
wer diesen kanal verfolgt hat hat von
anfang an mitbekommen dass diese
situation mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit eintreten würde warum
das so ist und warum ich mich persönlich
als einer der als risikogruppe massiv
betroffen wäre von einer corona
infektion also der krankheit cupid 19
warum ich mich auf eine ganz besondere
art vorbereitet habe und wie ich das
getan habe werde ich hier in diesem
video zum ersten mal erzählen klicks um
science-fiction er gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts habe sie bekommen
aus aktuellem anlass ist dieses video
komplett ohne skript aber ich will
versuchen alles zusammenfassend
zusammenzufassen was jetzt zu dieser
situation geführt hat wir haben ja viele
neue zahlen den letzten tagen bekommen
und die sind durchaus beunruhigend ganz
wichtig diskussion panikmache oder
verharmlosung es geht hier nicht und es
geht immer in der berichterstattung um
keins von beiden es geht darum wirklich
die situation so darzustellen wie sie
ist damit sich jeder darauf vorbereiten
kann
es gibt keinen grund zur panik es gibt
keinen grund dazu
auch das zu verharmlosen aber es gibt
grund zur sorge und es gibt gründe und
zwar sehr viele sich in einer bestimmten
art und weise zu verhalten und bestimmte
dinge zu tun
das fängt damit an dass jetzt bundesweit
immer mehr bundesländer veranstaltung
mit mehr als 1000 menschen verbieten
oder absagen
hier in berlin haben jetzt die amtsärzte
gefordert dass überhaupt veranstaltung
größere veranstaltungen zusammenkünfte
von menschen generell
verboten werden und was ist der
hintergrund der hintergrund ist nicht
dass jemand sich der jung ist der keine
vorerkrankung hat ansteckt weil das ist
relativ ungefährlich der grund ist wir
müssen die ältere generation schützen
ich gehöre so langsam mit dazu und ich
habe asthma ich habe eine
lungenentzündung sprich und ich bin ein
mann sprich bei mir ist das risiko im
fall einer erkrankung an coop 19
wirklich schwere komplikationen zu
bekommen
und ja im notfall auch an einer
lungenentzündung zu sterben sehr sehr
hoch und um uns menschen zu schützen
aber noch mehr diejenigen die über 80
sind denn dort wurde jetzt die gefahr
eines tödlichen verlaufs für diese
generation mit 25 prozent also mit einer
todesrate von 25 prozent eingesetzt das
heißt diese menschen sollte sollten mit
dem virus überhaupt nicht in verbindung
bekommt kommen
zum zweiten wurde eine erkrankungsrate
von 60 bis 70 prozent prognostiziert das
ist auch sehr realistisch ja diese zahl
kommt hier aus der biologie der charité
in berlin von dessen leiter christian
drosten
er sagt aus seiner epidemischen
erfahrung ist diese krankheitsrate zu
erwarten aus mathematischen gründen und
zwar weil immer mehr menschen angesteckt
werden und vor allem wenn es über einen
längeren zeitrahmen hinausgezögert wird
werden dann die erkrankung deutlich nach
unten gehen würden wir keine maßnahmen
ergreifen also und das ist ganz wichtig
wir haben ja in unserem video hier zum
thema alles was man was du über den
corona virus wissen muss alle
vorsichtsmaßnahmen die die
weltgesundheitsorganisation vor allem
empfiehlt aufgeführt ansonsten empfehle
ich noch mal auf die seite des robert
koch instituts zu gehen und zwar
möglichst oft weil dort immer wieder
neue ratschläge kommen und was mich
persönlich angeht habe ich mich genau
auf die
ratschläge die jetzt erst dort muss man
sagen veröffentlicht worden sind
vorbereitet das werde ich gleich
erzählen was ich da machen werde
die konsequenzen werden für mich
wirklich erheblich sein
so also es geht darum dass möglichst
wenig leute sicht in einem zeitabschnitt
anstecken das heißt anders herum gesagt
um so mehr menschen sich schnell
anstecken umso schneller verbreitet sich
das virus und das bedeutet eben für die
ältere generation eine riesen ein riesen
risiko muss man sagen weil dann auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit sich deutlich erhöht
dass sie sich anstecken im moment haben
wir zum beispiel hier in berlin 81
menschen die angesteckt sind man geht
davon aus beziehungsweise das löst immer
aus die 20 fache menge an menschen die
unter quarantäne müssen also sieht
nehmen im schnitt mit 20 personen
während sie noch nicht erkrankt sind
aber schon ansteckend sind kontakt auf
und das war übrigens hier auf dem kanal
immer der hauptgrund der sich jetzt halt
auch bewahrheitet hat warum diese
epidemie mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
zur pandemie werden würde weil eben man
schon ansteckend ist wenn man noch gar
keine symptome hat bzw
diese krankheit auch zum teil nur ganz
geringe symptome mit sich führt und dann
ist man trotzdem anstecken kind kinder
betrifft das in besonderen dh sie können
die haben eine ganz leichte symptome und
sind trotzdem eben hoch ansteckend und
alte menschen müssen sich davor schützen
deswegen wird jetzt eher empfohlen dass
enke nicht mehr ihre großeltern besuchen
nicht mehr anfassen nicht mehr mit ihm
kuscheln und so weiter und so fort das
ist wirklich extrem extrem gefährlich
und deswegen werden auch immer möglichst
schnell in risikogebieten kindergärten
und schulen geschlossen weil dort die
ansteckungsgefahr hoch ist also wir
müssen damit rechnen es werden hier
viele menschen angesteckt wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass das möglichst in einem
langen zeitraum geschieht was habe ich
also jetzt getan wenn man
die ratschläge des robert-koch-instituts
die jetzt dort veröffentlicht worden
sind befolgt heißt das ich darf nicht
mehr vor die tür gehen
ich darf mich kein mensch mehr näher
möglichst kein kontakt mehr mit menschen
haben
ich muss dafür sorgen dass ich alles was
ich anfasse desinfiziere
ja und wenn man da sich das anguckt ist
das extrem schwierig ich habe das in
diesen tagen ausprobiert wenn man
rausgeht man fast wirklich hunderte
dinge an von denen man nicht weiß könnte
sie heute ist das risiko noch gering
aber könnte sie in zukunft wenn die
verbreitung usa wird nicht eben ein mit
corona infizierter mensch angefasst
haben und das ist ein riesen risiko aus
diesem grunde habe ich mir schon vor
wochen vorräte angelegt und zwar für
etwa ein jahr
ich gehe davon aus dass sechs monate
reichen werden um diese zeit zu
überstehen weil man muss sich das auch
nur mal im supermarkt ansehen man fast
dort auch ex dinge an produkte die
andere menschen vorher angefasst haben
man steht in der schlange an der kasse
dort gibt es diesen mindestabstand von
einem meter nicht das heißt in dem
moment wo jemand in der kassenschlange
hinter mir oder vor mir stehen würde der
infiziert wäre wäre es für mich
unmöglich eine ansteckung zu verhindern
also das sind meine konsequenzen ich
werde euch hier auf dem laufenden halten
ich werde auf instagram ist hier unter
dem video und jetzt hier auch verlinkt
mit stories auf dem laufenden halten und
ansonsten klickt auf die playlist mit
allen videos von uns zur corona krise
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran